Qualitative research can be
a little bit difficult to pin down.
It's really exploration of
unstructured and naturalistic data.
For example,
if you are trying to develop a tool
that will improve learning, you might
interview some students that you hope
will use your tool to understand
what they struggle with and
what they like.
Or you might choose to observe
a classroom just in its natural
environment, taking notes on its
various dynamics that you see at play.
The downside of qualitative research
is that its often not as generalizable.
It might be transferable
to new environments, but
it doesn't generalize out to some
objective truce the way we can sometimes
get with quantitative data.
With education we often have
to use qualitative research
because there are so many things
going on in the classrooms, so
many things going on in
the learning process.
That boiling down to a couple
of clean numbers just
loses the real magic of what's going on.
So qualitative research is something we
use very often in educational research
because it helps us
capture the real range of
all the different interacting
parts of the learning process.
So here we'll talk about the different
kinds of qualitative research.
We'll talk about case studies and
interviews.
We'll talk about how to do them and how
to make sure that the conclusions that
you get out of these kinds of research
are still valid and sound and useful.